in wenigen momenten geht es los denn
bundeskanzler olaf scholz r stellt sich
erstmals seit amtsantritt den fragen der
abgeordneten nun gleich wenn man ihn ja
wir versuchen das livebild schon mal zu
sehen da sehen wir da tut sich etwas im
bundestag wir übertragen natürlich live
das könnte spannend werden urlaub scholz
hat sich bisher ja eher bedeckt gehabt
weg getauchte sagen seine kritiker und
wir wollen natürlich keine langweilige
rede hier übertragen
zum einen ist es keine rede sondern ist
eine fragestunde also die abgeordneten
können den neuen bundeskanzler befragen
aber wir haben wir hier sehen frau war
es eröffnet die sitzung wir wollen hier
deutschlands schnellste meinung mit
hinein holen und zwar mit nina schenk
ihr bei uns im studio unsere kolleginnen
aus der redaktion und mit mike mohring
dem ehemaligen cdu chef von thüringen
also die cdu jetzt die oppositionspartei
hallo herr mohring hallo grüß sie ja
also schön dass sie alle dabei sind
vielleicht während wir hier sehen wir
die bundestagspräsidentin noch die
einleitung macht kurzer erwartungen
tatsächlich bin nicht gespannt weil die
erste regierungsbefragung ist olaf
scholz der ja auch gleich mit respekt
vor dem parlament gesagt hat er will
jetzt schon in diese regierungsbefragung
gehen die war erst vor ostern geplant
aber er muss natürlich rede und antwort
stehen die hält das mit seinem
versprechen die impfpflicht einzuführen
gibt es ein gesetzentwurf der
bundesregierung oder gibt es doch immer
gruppen einträge da liefert die
regierungskoalition derzeit nicht und
das wird heute mit sicherheit thema
werden in dieser betragen was wäre die
schärfste frage die sie stellen würden
wenn sie mit drin werden
der bundeskanzler seine wahlversprechen
alle einheiten möchte uns seine zusage
gegeben hatte doch dieser
vertrauensbruch der iss begonnen hat zu
beginn der periode fortgesetzt wird
vertrauensbruch schwerer vorwurf fragen
hier bei uns im studio in den er deine
erwartungen wie gesagt olaf scholz ich
werde immer ein blick rüber auch auf das
live-bild aus dem bundestag olaf scholz
vielleicht verhalten weg getaucht sagen
manche jetzt am anfang ich erwarte schon
von ihnen heute dass er erstmal prägnant
auftritt und ich finde es auch gut dass
es vorgezogen wurde meine meinung deckt
sich etwas mit dem vom herr mohring wo
ich sagen muss hätten wir lieber mich zu
fragen wie ich die antwort gegeben nein
ich glaube schon dass wir heute auf
fragen zu krone natürlich erwarten
können und ich bin sehr gespannt wie er
scheut sich heute diesen fragen stellt
vor allem auch zweig plus ist ja auch
eine sache neben der impfpflicht über
die wir eigentlich noch zu wenig reden
was wäre deine frage an den
bundeskanzler meine frage wäre ganz klar
wie man einen kanzler sein will der ganz
deutschland und der auch der kanzler der
umgebung ist wenn man zweig plus sogar
in der herzkammer der demokratie unserem
bundestag einführt große debatte heute
vormittag hier auch bei uns ja in der
sendung schon ne saal verbot für
ungeimpfte die müssen also alle auf der
tribüne sitzen auch das wird interessant
zu beobachten sein welche bilder wir da
sehen da sehen wir den großen plenarsaal
über 700 abgeordnete nicht jeder wird
die gelegenheit haben eine frage zu
stellen denn es ist eine fragestunde wir
reden also hier von maximal 60 minuten
so ist es eigentlich vorgesehen
ja das war eine große diskussion heute
morgen saal verbot für ungeimpfte nena
ja
absolut also wir hatten heute morgen
auch schon unsere wirtschaft oder
gesellschaft claus strunz und der das ja
schon sehr bringen kommentiert und ich
bin absolut dagegen ich finde es ganz
schrecklich das wird dort jetzt
einstellen und heute nachmittag wird
auch noch mein kollege kai weise wird
mit sahra wagenknecht noch ein interview
auch heute schon führen darüber wie es
jetzt geht weil sie ist ja noch nicht
geimpft und das muss man mal sagen ich
finde diese debatten haben viel zu sein
gesicht also frau wagenknecht wird dann
sei verbot haben naja saal verboten in
dem sinne dass sie auf die tribüne muss
sie darf immer noch anwesend sein aber
verfolgt das ganze dann eben von oben
und selbst die reden dürfen ja dann
nicht mehr die ungeimpften dürfen nicht
mehr ans rednerpult darunter sollen auch
von der tribüne aus dann die reden
halten wenn zweig plus komplett
umgesetzt wird könnte es auch sein dass
frau wagenknecht sich digital zuschaltet
aber absolut also es ist schon ein
angriff also meiner meinung nach ist
zwei geflossen angriff
also ein angriff auf die demokratie das
darf einfach nicht sein und ich finde
sowieso generell gesprochen politiker
sollten natürlich das machen was auch
die bürger machen für mich ist zweig
plus aber eher ein absolutes unding und
ich finde wir müssen aufhören in einer
zwei klassen gesellschaft zu leben wir
müssen kroner pandemie anders bekämpfen
aber einer der das ja viel mehr dazu zu
sagen es kommt ja jetzt ist es immer
super spannend ich freue mich jetzt
schon richtig dass ich hier die stunde
bei euch verbringen darf weil das
eigentlich debatten jedes mal spannend
sind im bundestag zu sehen wären sie
auch den fragen stellte gespannt werden
mag morgen noch kurze einschätzung bevor
es gleich losgeht was halten sie davon
haben ihren parteikollegen viele beamte
heute morgen auch in der sendung gehabt
wäre sie durchaus anfreunden konnte mit
der neuen regelung zweig plus im
bundestag statt bisher drei statt wie
bisher 3 g
ja beispielsweise bei uns im thüringer
landtag wird das ja schon so gehandhabt
dass mal geimpft sein muss oder
tagesaktuell getestet und kommt man auch
nicht linear saarland tatsächlich sitzen
vor allen dingen abgeordnet oder
ausschließlich abgeordnete die auf der
tribüne und halten auch vom balkon ihrer
reden und ich muss sagen dann schlecht
wie schon in unheimliches gefühl wenn
dann ihren drucker oben auf dem dach der
empore steht und resi indes rund des
plenarsaals von da oben seine rede hält
quasi vom balkon da gilt zur assoziation
in der geschichte die wir waren nicht
gern haben aber es ist halt kompliziert
wie im richtigen leben etwas machen mit
den ungeimpften die sind leichter
infektiöser und der gesundheitsschutz
muss hat auch eine rolle spielen auch im
parlament und es ist eine gratwanderung
das ist kein dauer beispiel das kann
nicht auf dauer so gehen weil dann
machen wir sagt markus debatte im
parlament im plenarsaal kaputt wenn wir
sozusagen oben und unten abgeordnete
platzieren und das hat natürlich auch
was mit autos zu tun weil aktuell ist ja
noch nicht von allen politikern bekannt
nicht von jedem nicht jeder hat eben
seinen impfstatus offengelegt und sahra
wagenknecht wissen wir dass aber es wird
noch spannend sein zu sehen wer daneben
oben auf der tribüne platz nehmen muss
und wer weiterhin im plenarsaal sein
darf oder
ja absolut das ist es greift auch im
stück in die freiheit ist man da
irgendwo ein assist
wir machen ja quasi getesten der jeden
tag alle rechtlichen möglichkeiten aus
in dieser pandemie und wir lernen jeden
tag der zug und merken aber auch er weiß
ob er nicht wieder an grenzen stoßen und
dieser widerspruch die freiheit das
mandat ist damit sozusagen alles was
damit zusammenhängt dass das geschützt
ist aber selbst ganz einfach dass man
auch seine eigene gesundheitsfragen
selber versicht verantworten musste
nicht öffentlich deklarierten muss das
findet jetzt damit statt und so gesehen
wird es mit sicherheit auch noch
rechtliche auseinandersetzungen geben ob
das so funktioniert
mohring ganz herzlichen dank für diese
erste einschätzung deutschlands meinung
dann gleich von ihnen und jetzt gehen
wir rein in den bundestag und hören zu
bundeskanzler olaf scholz stellt sich
den fragen der abgeordneten
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
der bundeskanzler sagt bei der
bekämpfung des kroner virus darf es
keine roten linien geben ich sage ihnen
in einer freiheitlichen demokratie muss
es rote linien geben
gerade hier im deutschen bundestag
werden die heute einmal mehr
überschritten eine völlig neue
überzogene kroner verordnung greift tief
in das freie mandat der parlamentarier
ein selbst abgeordnete die sich hier
offiziell im bundestag direkt vor dieser
sitzung haben testen lassen und den
einwandfrei besteht bestätigt wurde dass
sie kein corona haben selbst diesen
abgeordneten wird jetzt der zutritt ins
plenum verweigert sie dürfen hier nicht
sitzen sie dürfen an diesem pult nicht
reden sie dürfen also ihre
verfassungsmäßige rechte nicht ausüben
das kann nicht sein das darf nicht sein
das kann nicht so bleiben meine damen
und herren
abgeordnete müssen jetzt über den klaren
negativ test hinaus zusätzlich noch
nachweise erbringen über doppelte
impfung oder genesung wozu das führende
deutsche verfassungsrechtler hat das
sofort alarmiert ich zitiere nur den
lehrstuhlinhaber für öffentliches recht
der universität oldenburg professor
boehme neßler warnte gestern mit blick
auf den bundestag sofort wörtlich
getesteten auf die tribüne zu verbannen
ist nicht erforderlich ist
unverhältnismäßig und ist damit
verfassungswidrig
deutlicher kann man es doch gar nicht
sagen meine damen und herren
sie schieben also nachweislich gesunde
auf die besuchertribüne ganz dort oben
wo sie von anderen abgeordneten nicht
gesehen werden sie halten also praktisch
saal verbot werden von der gemeinschaft
alle abgeordneten abgetrennt und so
schikaniert mit ihrer krone politik
spalten sie nicht nur die gesellschaft
spalten auch dieses parlament meine
damen und herren
denn gleichzeitig dürfen andere
abgeordnete hier im plenum völlig
ungetestet sitzen nur wegen einer
sogenannten booster impfung dabei weiß
mittlerweile jeder dass selbst dreifach
geimpfte das virus übertragen können
niemand weiß wie viel hier vorne in
wirklichkeit infiziert sind
die einzig vernünftige regel wäre
deshalb alle zu testen das aber tun sie
nicht sie setzten sich damit den
erkenntnissen der wissenschaft entgegen
überdies wegen sie jetzt auch noch alle
abgeordneten trotz abstand halten statt
normaler op masken jetzt die dicke ffp
zwei maske zu tragen immer und überall
den ganzen tag deren stunden langes
tragen
der schwerter atmen stört die
konzentration selbst professor wieder
präsident des robert koch-instituts
warnt diese masken seien für den alltag
nicht zu gebrauchen all diese
einschränkungen gefährden die arbeit der
abgeordneten spalten das parlament und
sie sind auch noch sinnlos wie sagt
bereits sehr zitierte staatsrechtler
wörtlich verfassungsmäßige rechte durch
sinnlose maßnahmen einzuschränken
erlaubt die verfassung auf gar keinen
fall halten sie sich daran meine damen
und herren
[Applaus]
als nächste rednerin für die spd
fraktion katja mast
[Applaus]
[Musik]
frau präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
kolleginnen und kollegen meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren heute morgen
die neuesten
infektionszahlen
1430 die höchsten infektionszahlen seit
beginn der pandemie in berlin
9000 neue infektionen und deshalb bin
ich froh dass die
bundestagspräsidentin die initiative
ergriffen hat die allgemeinverfügung zu
verändern es ist absolut geboten und es
ist richtig dass wir die notwendigen
maßnahmen zum schutz von uns allen in
die wege leiten
grundsätzlich will ich aber auch sagen
dass die rechte der abgeordneten die
ausübung des freien mandats
überhaupt nicht in gefahr sind trotz der
schon geltenden geänderten
allgemeinverfügung fühlen wir hier diese
freie und offene debatte das ist ein
beleg dafür
und im gegenteil mit dieser
allgemeinverfügung
stärken wir die funktionsfähigkeit des
deutschen bundestags und
gewährleisten damit dass auch wichtige
entscheidungen in zukunft weiterhin hier
getroffen werden können
und weil es nicht nur um die
mandatsträgerinnen und mandatsträger
sondern auch die mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter im deutschen bundestag in
den abgeordnetenbüros in der verwaltung
aber auch hier vor mir und hierbei den
saal dienerin und saaldiener geht es
geht auch um den schutz der
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter hier
immer aus da haben wir eine besondere
verantwortung dafür
und weswegen wir das regeln wir wir
führen eine ffp zwei masken pflicht ein
die gilt in berlin ab samstag in allen
bereichen wir machen nichts anderes als
das was die menschen draußen im land
auch tun im deutschen bundestag und 2g
plus in plenarsitzungen und
ausschusssitzungen und veranstaltungen
des bundestags bei jedem
restaurantbesuche zweige plus und wir
tun hier als wäre es im deutschen
bundestag nicht notwendig
es geht hier darum dass wir bieten
stimmt schutz der menschen im deutschen
bundestag genau so leben die menschen
müssen das auch tun wir erwarten es von
ihnen jeden tag und deshalb ist es
richtig dass wir das so machen und auch
ihre ablehnung überbrücken sieht mal wie
heute auch ob das sehr gut es gibt hier
vier fraktionen die sagen wir halten
abstand auch im plenarsaal
sie finden dass es nicht notwendig auch
das zeigt ihre fünf entschuldigung
fraktion im deutschen bundestag
zeigen dass und sie wollen einfach den
menschen sand in die augen streuen und
sagen wir können diese pandemie nicht in
den griff bekommen durch unser volk nun
das gegenteil ist der fall es verhelfen
von jedem einzelnen von jeder einzelnen
hat auswirkungen für die gesundheit in
diesem land und deshalb ist es richtig
was die parlamentspräsidentin in die
wege geleitet hat vielen dank für diese
änderung der allgemeinen
[Musik]
hallo ja gar ein wir schon gemerkt dass
so richtig die emotionen im kessel sind
katja mast von der spd hat gerade
gesprochen das war aber noch nicht die
fragestunde sondern die debatte zur
geschäftsordnung aber die frage schon
gespannt wie man an den emotionen
gemerkt hat
ist der frei
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen es ist in der tat die frage zu
stellen worüber reden wir eigentlich
über eine verschärfte masken pflicht und
über 2g hier im plenum des deutschen
bundestages und ich will das für unsere
fraktion ganz klar sagen wir halten das
für eine richtige und für eine
notwendige entscheidung denn es ist doch
wirklich darauf hinzuweisen in welchem
umfeld bewegen wir uns es sind nicht nur
erstmals mehr als 80.000 neue
infektionen am heutigen tag wir haben
ein infektionsgeschehen das etwa 130
prozent über dem des vorjahreszeitraums
liegt und wir haben die situation dass
wir hier in berlin mitte eine inzidenz
von neun
176,2 haben und deswegen muss man sich
doch auch fragen welches bild wir als
parlament in der öffentlichkeit abgeben
wir verlangen von den menschen
einschränkungen in form von
schutzmaßnahmen und wir als abgeordnete
wäre nicht bereit diese maßnahmen auch
für uns gelten zu lassen das ist nicht
akzeptabel dass es keine führung von
vorne und deswegen ist es wichtig was in
der allgemeinverfügung der präsidentin
drin steht
es sind nicht nur die menschen die man
ich will das auch an die kollegen sagen
von jedem schulkind in deutschland
erwarten wir dass es sich testen lässt
und sie und sie vergessen hier
krokodilstränen und schwadronieren über
die einschränkungen die damit verbunden
sind das ist nicht akzeptabel und
deswegen machen wir es so wie die frau
präsidentin vorgeschlagen hat
hier werden emotionen gespielt es wird
auf die schulkinder verwiesen meine
meinung ist dass schulkinder soll ich
mich als jeden tag testen müssen und
dieser vergleich
zu verhindern und es geht auch darum
dass wir die funktionsfähigkeit des
deutschen bundestages
aufrechterhalten weil wir dafür sorgen
müssen dass wir auch in zukunft in der
lage sind hier im bundestag die
notwendigen beschlüsse für die zukunft
unseres landes zu treffen und deswegen
verehrte frau präsidentin bin ich ihnen
und sind wir uns sind wir ihnen als
unions fraktion ausdrücklich dankbar
dafür dass sie hier das heft des
handelns in die hand genommen haben dass
sie die notwendigen maßnahmen getroffen
haben dass sie führung gezeigt haben
eine führung liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wie wir sie uns auch von der
bundesregierung und den bundeskanzler
erwarten würden führung in schwieriger
zeit führung in einer der größten krisen
unseres landes diese führung erwarten
wir und deswegen verehrter herr schulz
nehmen sie sich ein beispiel an unserer
parlamentspräsidentin herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
weitere wortmeldungen zur
geschäftsordnung liegen mir nicht vor
wir kommen damit nun zur abstimmung über
die eben erläuterte 2d plus regel sowie
über die verschärfte masken pflicht im
plenarsaal als teil unserer
parlamentarischen ordnung
wer stimmt dafür
dass in die fraktion die linke spd
bündnis 90 die grünen fdp cdu csu
fraktion wer stimmt dagegen das ist die
afg fraktion gibt es enthaltungen
das sehe ich nicht damit sind die neuen
regeln als teil unserer
parlamentarischen ordnung beschlossen
wir kommen nun zu weiteren tagesordnung
für die heutige zehnte die morgige elfte
und die zwölfte sitzung am freitag haben
die fraktionen eine tagesordnung
vereinbart mit der ich den bundestag
einberufen habe nach § 21 absatz 3 der
geschäftsordnung ist für die genehmigung
der tagesordnung ein plenar- beschluss
erforderlich
interfraktionell ist vereinbart worden
die noch zu beschließende tagesordnung
um die in der zusatzpunkt liste
aufgeführten punkte zu erweitern von der
frist für den beginn der beratung soll
soweit erforderlich abgewichen werden
tagesordnungspunkt 4 wird abgesetzt
damit kommen wir zur feststellung der
tagesordnung der zehnten elften und
zwölften sitzung mit den genannten
änderungen wer ist für diese
tagesordnung
das sind alle fraktionen gibt es
gegenstimmen
keine enthaltung auch nicht das wundert
mich weil ich
weil ich gedacht habe die tagesordnung
wenn nicht vereinbart aber das finde ich
gut herzlich herzlichen dank dann
könnten wir uns diesen prozess
vielleicht in zukunft sparen vielen dank
ja da hat man also schon mal sparkassen
haben festgestellt meine damen und
herren interessante momente die wir hier
erleben auf live dabei zunächst einmal
ist also im bundestag abgestimmt dass
ungeimpfte abgeordnete nicht mehr nah
sein dürfte nun eine große mehrheit
dafür alle außerhalb der afd die
fragestunde mit dem bundeskanzler
beginnt dann jetzt in diesem moment
firma wieder rein
präsidentin meine damen und herren die
bundesregierung hat sich heute erneut
mit dem thema beschäftigt das uns eben
auch schon bewegt hat nämlich die frage
der korona pandemie entschuldigung herr
kanzler jetzt unterbrechen ist sie weil
sie alle liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wissen dass das eine politische aktion
ist die wir hier in diesem hause nicht
dulden und insofern bitte ich sie jetzt
sofort das runter zu nehmen sonst muss
ich sie des saales verweisen und ich
behalte mir auch vor ein entsprechendes
ordnungsgeld für die ganze fraktion im
zweifel zu verhängen
jetzt ziemlich zügig
übrigens auch da oben weil sonst
und zwar alle sind erst einmal gerade
gesehen die afg hat natürlich die
aufmerksamkeit für die erste
regierungsbefragung von bundeskanzler
genutzt um ein zeichen zu setzen was
aber nach der geschäftsordnung nicht
erlaubnis solche verbalen äußerungen
plakaten mit dem nachschlag sehen glaubt
es sind jetzt die präsidentin gerade die
abgeordnete fdp und drohte ihn auch
wieder verweisen sie alles an ihn wenn
sie der aufforderung nicht nach
probieren
und jetzt der bundeskanzler bitte ich
sie einfach noch mal an zu setzen und so
dass wir auch in die befragung des
bundeskanzlers gehen können frau
präsidentin meine damen und herren
kroner ich habe es schon gesagt ist das
thema das uns in diesen tagen alle
umtreibt die bundesregierung hat sich
heute erneut damit beschäftigt und
deshalb die kinder schutz verordnung auf
den weg gebracht das ist allerdings eine
teil entscheidung im rahmen vieler
vieler weiteren entscheidungen die wir
in der letzten zeit getroffen haben und
die vorbereitet worden sind hier in
diesem haus aber vorbereitet worden sind
in gemeinsamen zusammen in
zusammenkünften der länder und der
bundesregierung im november im dezember
und jetzt auch noch anfang januar wir
haben dabei entscheidungen vorbereitet
die dazu geführt haben dass deutschland
mit großer klarheit den weg durch die
pandemie weiter geht dazu gehören sehr
weitreichende kontakt beschränkung
weitreichender als in fast allen anderen
ländern der europäischen union
das gilt insbesondere wenn man sie in
der zusammenschau betrachtet wir haben
kontakt beschränkung im privaten bereich
nicht mehr als zehn personen und dort wo
die beteiligten nicht geschützt sind ist
es so dass nur zwei weitere hinzukommen
können wir haben kontakt beschränkungen
im bereich
von zusammenkünften mit 2g und 2g plus
wir haben jetzt neu beschlossen dass das
auch gelten soll für den besuch von
restaurants als zweig plus wir haben
kontakt beschränkungen die die größe von
veranstaltungen betrifft das sind sehr
weitreichende maßnahmen sie haben aber
auch ihren gewünschten effekt denn das
infektionsgeschehen dass mit der neuen
omikron -variante verbundene ist in
deutschland in ganz anderer weise als
anderswo bisher verzeichnet worden und
das ist auch zurückzuführen auf die
klaren weitreichenden maßnahmen die wir
festgelegt haben
[Applaus]
persönlich finde ich ländervergleich
immer etwas schwierig dass es bei uns
dann besser läuft man könnte aber hier
zum beispiel auch über schweden reden
ich finde da macht es sich unser
bundeskanzler in diesem moment etwas zu
einfach zu loben dass die maßnahmen
wirken da gibt es auch andere länder mit
dem man das vergleichen gesellschaft bis
weihnachten 30 millionen solcher booster
impfung zustande zu bringen das war
unser gemeinsames ziel und wir arbeiten
jetzt daran
wir arbeiten jetzt daran dass es uns
gelingt weiter solche impfungen und
musterung zu organisieren wenn es uns
gelingt wieder auf das niveau vor
weihnachten zu kommen das ist mein
ehrgeiz wenn die ferien jetzt überall in
deutschland zu ende sind über eine
million impfungen pro tag zustande zu
bringen in den vielen impfzentren und
impfmöglichkeiten in den arztpraxen dann
werden wir es auch schaffen dass das
auch einen weiteren eigenen beitrag zur
bekämpfung der pandemie leistet trotzdem
ist eins klar und das wissen wir sehr
genau
wir werden das infektionsgeschehen auch
sehen dass wir in anderen ländern haben
mit mehr infektionen wegen der omicron
valiant
85.000 urlaub stolz macht mit seinem
statement zu beginn der
regierungsbefragung noch einmal seinen
standpunkt klar was auf der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz im kabinett
beschlossen wurde aber es hilft aber
eine wichtige aussage die er noch vor
tagen getroffen hat nämlich dass über 80
prozent der erstimpfung quote dort ein
zimmer in deutschland immer noch weit
entfernt dieses ziel hat er erzählt aber
er hat hier keine weitere begründung
gegeben wir diesen makel noch erreichen
möchte also da ist der erste schritt
wurden erfahrung zu sehen dank bei
voland man keine fragen gestellt hatten
hier im deutschen bundestag nun wo er
wieder zusammentritt auch beginnt und
ich hoffe dass es eine zügige gute
beratung geben wird mit einer
entsprechenden ergebnis ich jedenfalls
halte sich für notwendig und werde mich
aktiv dafür einsetzen
wir entscheiden mit allem was wir
entscheiden nicht nur über uns und nicht
nur für uns allein denn die tatsache
dass in deutschland nicht so viele
geimpft sind wie wir am anfang der
impfkampagne gehofft haben als wir noch
gerungen haben darum dass möglichst
viele eine impfung überhaupt bekommen
können die tatsache dass wir nicht hoch
genug gekommen sind hat auch
konsequenzen
konsequenzen die mit den maßnahmen
zusammenhängen über die ich eben
geschrieben habe aber auch konsequenzen
die zum beispiel bedeuten dass wir
mittel bereitgestellt haben dafür dass
krankenhäuser operationen verschieben
können damit genügend betten für corona
infizierte zur verfügung stehen und
deshalb gibt es nicht die entscheidung
wo jemand sagt mich betrifft das ja
nicht ich entscheide für mich ich kämpfe
mich nicht und das hat keine
konsequenzen für andere
doch für unser ganzes land für die
eigenen freunde für die nachbarn hat die
tatsache dass man jemanden anstecken
könnte eine konsequenz zum beispiel die
vielen mittel die wir
hier würde ich mir wünschen dass olaf
scholz auch auf die menschen eingeht die
vielleicht angst verspüren hielt
nebenwirkungen hatten aber auch etwas
sehr positives zu sagen wer gefällt wir
souveräner auftritt ich finde seine
weise die rhetorik ist sehr gut wie er
dort steht und auch wer sich gekleidet
hat für heute erhielt staatsmännisch aus
und findet in sicherheit
heute
finden erstmals wieder seit langer zeit
gespräch hier im nato-russland-rat stadt
gestern haben gespräche stattgefunden
zwischen den usa und russland es wird
gespräche geben im rahmen der osze und
wir sorgen aktiv dafür dass es wieder
möglichkeiten gibt das gesprächsformat
das normandie format zu beleben zwischen
den ländern die das auf den weg gebracht
haben um die krise in der ukraine zu
überwinden das ist eine ernste bedrohung
der sicherheit in europa der
truppenaufmarsch entlang der
ukrainischen grenze muss und sorge
machen und er macht mir persönlich auch
sehr sehr große sorgen es ist etwas
passiert
mit der annexion der krim nämlich dass
eine eroberte sicherheit eine die wir
politisch erobert haben miteinander in
europa das sicherheit nur gemeinsam
erreicht werden kann verloren gegangen
ist denn eine grundkonstante gehört
immer dazu die gemeinsame erklärung dass
grenzen in europa nicht mehr verschoben
werden dass die territoriale integrität
der staaten ungefährdet bleibt und wir
müssen durch zu dieser situation wieder
zurückkehren das werden wir tun
eingebettet in die europäische union und
den die nato zusammen mit unseren
amerikanischen verbündeten werden wir
hier klar
dafür dass das gefällt mir gut dass olaf
scholz jetzt nicht nur noch einer
spricht in seinem statement sondern auch
die auf gute vorlagen
auch seine rolle als bundesregierung
damit definiert aber sind auch wohltuend
abweichen würden seien
spd-generalsekretär diesen tagen ja
gesagt hatten die blick auf russland
alles in ordnung da gibt es gar keine
debatten weiter sondern aufmerksam
gemacht wie heikel die lage ist der
kleine ist
darauf macht wieder das land gefährde
und dass da jetzt gespräche müssen die
gemacht die deutschen motiven ergreifen
ist damit die neuen formate das war ein
wichtiger punkt und ich finde dass es
sehr gut dass wir gleich zu sehen sie
das der regen hat des ganzen hauses und
unserer ganzen republik und deshalb ist
es eine gute woche für ein signal des
aufbruchs schönen dunk
vielen dank herr bundeskanzler ich habe
bereits eine lange liste von
fragestellerin und fragestellern genannt
bekommen und wir beginnen mit
thorsten frei für die cdu/csu-fraktion
dass kanzler sie haben jetzt in ihren
ausführungen noch einmal erwähnt dass
die impfpflicht aus ihrer sicht ein
wichtiger bestandteil auf dem weg aus
der pandemie ist sie haben das auch
begründet diese meinung kann man teilen
oder auch nicht aber jedenfalls ist es
doch so dass wenn der bundeskanzler in
der größten krise unserer zeit sagt das
ist der weg aus der krise
dann muss der bundeskanzler und seine
regierung doch einen vorschlag einen
gesetzgebungsvorschlag dafür
unterbreiten wie man das ethisch richtig
und verfassungsrechtlich korrekt machen
kann und
wenn sie nicht die kraft dazu haben
einen solchen
gesetzgebungsvorschlag hier in den
deutschen bundestag einzubringen wo wir
ihn selbstverständlich diskutieren und
entscheiden und abgeordnete auch so
entscheiden wie sie es für richtig
halten dann müssen sie doch wenigstens
die fragen die aus diesem parlament
gestellt werden um eine solche frage
beurteilen zu können beantworten das
haben sie beispielsweise für unsere
fraktion nicht gemacht wir haben ihnen
vor weihnachten zahlreiche fragen
gestellt die für uns essenziell sind um
dieses thema zu bearbeiten und deswegen
möchte ich ihnen die frage stellen was
muss in unserem land passieren dass sie
bereit sind in einer so entscheidenden
frage die fragen der opposition und des
parlaments zu beantworten
schönen dank für ihre frage und für die
gelegenheit noch mal zu wiederholen was
im übrigen allseits bekannt ist an
position der bundesregierung und auch
des bundeskanzlers zu diesem thema ich
habe eben schon gesagt ich halte eine
impfpflicht für erforderlich ich habe
bereits als ich das im november das
erste mal gesagt habe und damit der
debatte in deutschland auch eine
richtung gegeben habe die vorher nicht
zu erkennen war dass ich von vornherein
richtig fand dass dies eine so
grundsätzliche angelegenheit ist dass es
besser ist sie geschieht auf basis von
anträgen aus diesem haus ohne regierung
und opposition und fraktionszwängen
sondern es eine entscheidung die die
abgeordneten ganz bewusst in dieser
frage anders treffen
selbstverständlich
selbstverständlich ist es so
dass die bundesregierung alle hilfe
bereitstellt für diese anträge und
selbstverständlich ist es so dass der
abgeordnete olaf scholz auch eine ganz
klare meinung
und deshalb will ich und ja immer genau
dann kern angekommen was es hier geht
die opposition das cdu zuerst würde ich
sagen recht kanzlei ausliefern muss
vorlage ein nachdenken befördern dass
einschreitens das ist bundeskanzler sagt
das ist sache der parlamente
spiritualität geld dabei
hilfestellung dafür ist aber noch wann
also nicht eine entscheidung treffen
wenn das licht nicht laufen denn wenn
man als kannst du sogar irgendwie
wundert stolz und sage ich will nicht
regeln deutschland werde sich das merkt
schaltung fällen sitzt auf seiner
regierung die kraft hat dann macht man
das nicht nur dem parlament zu
überlassen wo du bist ein schwarzer
peter gespielt pandemie und der ist
infektionsgeschehen es ganz genau und
deshalb wäre es gut dass neben den
vielen entschlossenen entschiedenen
maßnahmen die wir in deutschland
ergriffen haben diese maßnahme als
zusätzliche am horizont fest geregelt
ist damit alle bürgern und bürger sich
daran orientieren können
herr frey sie haben die möglichkeit eine
nachfrage zu stillen ja ja dann mache
ich davon gebrauch herr bundeskanzler
sie haben ja auch der bisherigen
bundesregierung angehört und wir haben
im dezember hier im deutschen bundestag
eine
berufsbezogene impfpflicht für profit 19
beschlossen können sie mir mal erklären
wo jetzt der unterschied liegt zwischen
der einbringung eines gesetzesvorschlags
der bundesregierung damals und einer
gewissensentscheidung heute
erstens
als jemand der diesem parlament schon
mehrere legislaturperioden angehört hat
und auch eine ganz tolle aufgabe in
diesem rahmen hatte einmal als erster
parlamentarischer geschäftsführer
einer dieser fraktion will ich
ausdrücklich sagen mir ist wichtig dass
jede einzelne entscheidung eine ist wo
jeder abgeordnete für sich selber
entscheiden ob er dem common folgen will
dass man dem mehrheitsvotum seiner
fraktion feucht oder ob man das in
diesem fall anders sehen will man muss
es sich immer nur habe ich den
abgeordneten die anders abstimmen
wollten als die fraktionen erläutert
genau überlegen denn auch da trifft man
nicht nur eine entscheidung für sich
sondern das muss man allen anderen ja
erläutern es gibt aber fragen wo wir uns
darüber verständigt haben auch in diesem
parlament dass sie so von so
grundlegender bedeutung sind dass es der
sache dient wenn man einen anderen weg
geht also kein vorschlag der regierung
macht sondern vorschläge aus dem
haushalt über die dann abgestimmt wird
und dies ist einer dieser fälle die er
gar nicht so selten sind und die aber
alle wenn wir diesen weg gegangen sind
immer zur befriedung der politischen
diskussion beigetragen habe und deshalb
ist mein beitrag dazu erstens ganz von
vorne weg gesagt zu haben ich bin dafür
als noch die meisten nicht dafür waren
zweitens den weg zu öffnen für diese
offene debatte und was ihre konkrete
frage betrifft was ist der unterschied
das finde ich jetzt schon etwas
humorvoll waren herr scholz tonen das
erschien dafür andere noch nicht waren
vor der wahl war er nicht dafür und die
ungeimpften wählerstimmen waren auch
noch gut genug ich finde es etwas
schwierig jetzt zu betonen dass man ja
dafür war hätte ja auch schon vor der
wahl sein da habe ich auch sondern wenn
wir eine impfpflicht festsetzen betrifft
das jeden einzelnen bürgern und bürger
jede bürgerin jeden bürger geht es um
unsere körper die wir alle haben und
deshalb ist es genau ein solcher fall wo
man diesen weg gehen soll es ist der
richtige es ist der richtige weg für
demokratische leadership
[Musik]
vielen dank normalerweise ist es ja so
dass man auch nachfragen jetzt aus
anderen fraktionen stellt ich will im
moment ich will das ganz offen sagen
davon absehen weil ich sehr viele
anmeldungen sowieso schon habe und ich
glaube es wird auch dadurch sehr
lebendig so dass möglichst viele
fragestellerin und fragesteller auch
dran kommen und ich möchte auch alle
auch den herrn bundeskanzler noch mal
bitten dieser rote balken der berühmte
ist dafür da dass wir die redezeiten
dann auch sowohl der fragestellerin und
fragesteller aber auch von ihnen
einhalten nach möglichkeit damit eben
möglichst viele abgeordnete auch zu wort
kommen können die nächste frage stellt
für die spd-fraktion im bernd westphal
vielen dank frau präsidentin sehr
geehrter herr bundeskanzler
mit beginn des jahres hat deutschland
die g7 präsidentschaft übernommen mich
interessiert welche schwerpunkte sie
aufgrund der bundesregierung formuliert
haben und vor allen dingen welche
schwerpunkte sie einbringen wollen in
bezug auf die transformation der
wirtschaft für die g7 staaten
schönen dank
die frage in der tat die g7
präsidentschaft ist in dieser zeit mit
einer ganz großen herausforderungen
verbunden
wir haben uns eine sehr klare agenda
vorgenommen die wir verfolgen worden im
gespräch mit den anderen demokratischen
industriestaaten mit denen wir uns dort
versammeln denn das ist ja das was uns
zusammen
es geht einmal dass wir die große jetzt
könnte man sehen ob die koalition diese
geschafft sein verein kein geld gehabt
dort war es mit leuten auf seinen
regierungsnahen wir im rahmen des 7 das
ist kokolores ist es weiß ja auch selbst
zurück und ich glaube die veranstaltung
nicht dazu geeignet hat dass man
sozusagen gefälligkeits fragen stellt
das wirklich ein austausch stattfindet
aus der opposition mit der regierung
wenn ich gefälligkeiten hier
ausgetauscht werden an der kooperieren
wollen das auch tun worden wir werden in
unseren ländern ganz unterschiedliche
maßnahmen ergreifen um den klimawandel
zu bekämpfen sie werden alle auch
herausforderung mit sich bringen für die
industrie man muss sich dann verabreden
dass man einander nicht bekämpft sondern
in die gleiche richtung marschiert es
gibt weitere große frage punkte die ich
aber hier und skizzieren will wegen der
kurzen zeit für die antwort also es geht
um die frage wie wir corona bekämpfen
können weiter als große
gemeinschaftliche aufgabe in der welt
denn wir werden das nicht nur in einem
einzelnen land gehen es geht um
infrastruktur entwickeln und es geht
natürlich auch insgesamt um all die
fortschrittlichen dinge die wir in der
welt auf den weg bringen müssen also
viele viele themen
vielen dank herr westphal sie haben die
möglichkeit eine nachfrage zu stärken
davor präsident in dem ich gerne wahr
gleichzeitig haben unsere französischen
freunde ab januar die eu
ratspräsidentschaft übernommen sehen sie
auch in dieser verbindung synergien und
vielleicht gemeinsame dinge die man den
abstimmung mit den anderen
mitgliedstaaten der europäischen union
in gang bringen kann es ist sehr gut
dass frankreich jetzt gleichzeitig mit
uns diese präsidentschaft dann hat weil
wir dann eng kooperieren können und das
haben wir uns auch fest vorgenommen bei
den gesprächen die wir schon miteinander
haben konnten zum ende des letzten
jahres
wie mike mohring ist eben bei der
vorherigen umfrage festgestellt hat ist
auch hier festzustellen auch wieder aus
dem spd lager natürlich eine
gefälligkeit frage war aber auch als
kanzlerin merkel war nie anders auch da
kommt immer aus der eigenen partei
natürlich er nette fragen gang und gäbe
ganz normal es ist natürlich richtig
dass man das einbindet in die von mir
schon skizzierte internationale
kooperation einen klima klub damit nicht
an streit um gewissermaßen
celle stattfindet sondern eine
gemeinsame anstrengung zur bekämpfung
des klimawandels
zum aufhalten des klimawandels
vorgenommen werden wird und die themen
die wir ansonsten haben sind natürlich
verbunden auch mit der pandemie wie
kriegen wir die wirtschaft der länder
weiter vorangebracht wir haben mit dem
europäischen wiederaufbau programm eine
grundlage gelegt und die wollen wir
jetzt auch für die zukunft so entwickeln
dass die länder auch nach der krise
weiter
vorankommen um wachsen kann
vielen dank als nächster fragesteller
für die afg fraktion timo grub alam
vielen dank herr bundeskanzler die
korona maßnahmen aber auch krone an sich
verschleiert er den blick von den
wirklichen problemen das hat man ja in
ihren ausführungen zu anfang auch
deutlich wahrgenommen wir stehen in
deutschland vor massiven problemen
herausforderungen veränderungen die
unsere bürger wirklich umtreiben neben
den
unverhältnismäßigen
freiheitsbeschränkung treibt die bürger
natürlich auch streiten steigende
verbraucherpreise explodierende
energiekosten und eine massive
ansteigende inflation um der sektor
energie versorgung ist ein prominentes
beispiel die abschaffung der eeg-umlage
wird die erhöhung der co2 steuer abgabe
aufgezehrt die politik kann dafür sorgen
den strom für die breite masse der
gesellschaft auch wieder bezahlbar zu
halten weitere beispiele für eine
entlastung der normalen bürger liefern
unsere europäischen nachbarn zum
beispiel polen senkt die mehrwertsteuer
auf kraftstoffe aber auch für verbrauchs
gegenstände das hat meine frage mit
welchen politischen maßnahmen werden sie
der inflation entgegenwirken die ja
wirklich mittlerweile auch im eu-raum
ausufernd ist und wie sieht eigentlich
ihre exit-strategie aus der korona zeit
aus wanna bundeskanzler kann die
wirtschaft können die bürger in diesem
land wieder frei atmen
schönen dank für ihre frage will die
letzte zuerst beantworten über die wir
ja eben auch schon gesprochen habe ich
glaube dass genau die strategie die wir
hierzulande verfolgen die richtige ist
kontakt beschränkungen festzusetzen
insbesondere für diejenigen die bisher
den weg nicht gefunden haben zu einer
impfung aber auch insgesamt dadurch
dafür zu sorgen dass das
infektionsgeschehen nicht so explodiert
wie es ohne die maßnahmen die wir
ergriffen haben explodieren würde und
gleichzeitig alle aufrufen sich impfen
zu lassen diejenigen die schon im schutz
haben aufzurufen und eine dritte impfung
sich zu holen weil das dazu beiträgt
dass wir mit der pandemie besser umgehen
können und wir haben ja schon in den
letzten ferien in den letzten jahren der
pandemie aber auch jetzt immer noch sehr
umfassende wirtschaftshilfen auf den weg
gebracht um arbeitsplatz und wirtschaft
zu retten von der kurzarbeit angefangen
fortgesetzt bis hin zu den möglichkeiten
die wir für jedes einzelne unternehmen
auf den weg gebracht haben was die frage
betrifft wie wir mit den energiepreisen
umgehen können wollen ganz klar da ist
ein globales problem die preise steigen
überall in der welt die werden teurer
wenn man sie auf den internationalen
märkten einkaufen will und deshalb ist
es notwendig dass man etwas macht eine
der maßnahmen die wir ergreifen wollen
haben sie schon skizziert aber ein
bisschen klein gemacht wir wollen
spätestens anfang nächsten jahres die
eeg-umlage abschaffen und das ist genau
das vorhaben das dazu beiträgt dass jede
familie um 300 euro entlastet wird das
aber gleichzeitig dazu beiträgt dass
viele mittelständische unternehmen auch
eine entlastung bekommen
der copa sie haben die möglichkeit eine
nachfrage zu stellen ja also ich mir
geht es nicht nur um die unternehmen da
geht es auch um die allgemeinen bürger
die
ja man haben und herren da sind wir
wieder da herr mohring ihr eindruck
der kanzler der das format nutzt ich
habe das gerne geschaut bei angela
merkel
hat dieser regierungsbefragung diese
erst seit 2009 10 gibt immer auch
genutzt und manchmal auch mit einer
kleinen spitzen zu den parlamentariern
auch noch mal eine antwort zurück zu
spiegeln da ist urlaub sollten noch
nicht so weit aber er hat das sehr
staatsministerin gemacht und kann man
nur sagen das ist ein guter start für
ihn auch wenn man jetzt sieht die
debatte ist ganz viel zählt er versucht
natürlich jeder aus seinen politischen
feld die frage zu stellen und die
antwort die kommt es gar nicht an weil
man schon weiß was auch gesagt wird aber
trotzdem ist das modell der
regierungsbefragung gute war dass scholz
hat sich doch heute gut geschlagen
frage auch endlich nena hat eine
einschätzung wie er sich geschlagen hat
würde ich ihm sogar eine zwei geben ein
gut weil ich wirklich finde er hat sich
souverän geschlagen er hat und das fand
ich sehr angenehm bei der afc ich meine
die afg das hat mich übrigens
erschrocken in der herzkammer demokratie
wie diese diese plakate aufgerufen
werden freiheit statt spaltung und ich
bin ja auch eine große
freiheitskämpferin aber es ist natürlich
ein schlechtes gefühl was sie selber
bekommt wenn man es sieht finde ich dass
die afg dann da die partei die sich für
die freiheit ein steht schaut sich damit
souverän umgegangen hat souverän auch
die frage der afg entgegengenommen ich
finde scholz als ich heute sehr
staatsmännisch
gezeigt ich fand ihn heute eigentlich
nicht viel schlechter als wenn man das
ist mit angela merkel vergleicht von
früher also in den letzten befragungen
so lang ist ja noch nicht weg ich fand
das war eine zweifel sein auftritt
inhaltlich kann ich natürlich viel
dagegen sagen
ja zu sehen wie an dem tag an dem
beschlossen wird dass ungeimpfte auf die
tribüne säulen um die sozusagen anderen
auch nichts wird zu gefährden und weil
die regel als sonst im land auch so geht
die fdp abgeordneten demonstrativ ganz
ganz eng zusammen setzen und nicht
auseinander und dann auch noch die
schilder dort
wir haben unsere reporterin angelika
hellemann auch vor ort weiß nicht ob sie
jetzt schon in der lage ist uns
zugeschaltet zu werden ansonsten noch
mal die frage an
mike mohring was glauben sie sind jetzt
die größten herausforderungen
da sehe ich sie ja angelika hellemann
ist da sehe ich sie besser kannst du
mich auch in amerika
ich kann nicht klar und deutlich höheren
wunderbar du warst du vor ort bis dort
im bundestag sagt mir doch da einen
eindruck
ja es ging halt etwas turbulent zu eben
durch die geschäftsordnungsdebatte und
die aktion der afd olaf scholz aus der
ruhe zu bringen ist relativ schwer
nerven stark ist der mann das heißt da
reagiert er einfach gar nichts auch
keinerlei regung das ist dann auch die
richtige reaktion auf solche
provokationen und jetzt beginnt halt mit
so ungefähr naja 20 minuten verspätung
tatsächlich die befragung des kanzlers
das ist mal unter angela merkel
eingeführt worden dass die abgeordneten
den kanzler die kanzlerin befragen
dürfen bislang läuft das ebenso wie
erwartet die unionsfraktion hat inhalt
sofort zur impfpflicht befragt das hat
er ja so pariert wie man olaf scholz
kennt also sehr ruhig relativ monotone
stimme und bei so einer
regierungsbefragung durch die
oppositionsabgeordneten versucht ein
kanzler halt auch möglichst wenig raus
zu lassen keine nachrichten zu setzen
das einzige wasser zur impfpflicht
gesagt hat ist dass sie eben für
volljährige sprich ab 18 kommen soll das
war aber eigentlich schon klar und dass
es ohne große bürokratie so schlank wie
möglich passieren soll das heißt kein
ins register dass es dem ganzen
geschuldet dass der aufbau eines images
das offenbar sehr lange dauert also viel
zu lange dann sind wir wohl tatsächlich
aus der panne mir aus und auch die fdp
fraktion aus datenschutzrechtlichen
gründen ein impf register überhaupt
nicht mitmachen würde und jetzt beginnt
gerade das spiel das heißt die
opposition wird immer wieder auf der
impfpflicht rumreiten und ihm vorhalten
dass er eben selbst nicht führt dass er
keine initiative zeigt dass er kein
gesetzentwurf vorlegt und nicht wirklich
raus lässt wie er es haben will und die
abgeordneten der ampel fraktionen werden
ihm erst sehr ruhige sehr liebe fragen
stellen bei denen dann olaf scholz ein
bisschen über sein regierungsprogramm
quatschen kann eigentlich sind die
fragestunde ja dazu dass ein austausch
stattfindet zwischen opposition und der
regierung angelika aber so eine richtige
überraschung hat irgendwie nicht dabei
das wissen wir alles schon was wir heute
ja das liegt also erst mal daran das ist
ein ganz ganz starkes konzept ist also
der kanzler darf eine minute lang eine
antwort geben ab dann springt von
rothens
zeitbalken auf rot dann ist er also
schon überfällig der fragesteller hat
auch immer nur eine minute zeit für
seine fragestellung und er darf nur eine
nachfrage stellen das heißt eine frage
an olaf scholz er antwortet ich darf
einmal nachfragen und danach ist ein
anderer abgeordneter hat daran dass
heißt es springt von den themen auch die
ganze zeit munter lustig hin und her und
da sich die opposition mit
cdu/csu afd und linker überhaupt nicht
abspricht dann gibt es eben auch nichts
wo man ihn wirklich in die zange nehmen
könnte und dazwischen quatschen dann
halt immer die ampel abgeordneten mit er
netten fragen so nach dem motto was hast
du dir denn vorgenommen bei europa oder
der ratspräsidentschaft also sachen die
er wirklich im ff einfach beantworten
kann anordnungen von angelika hellemann
aus dem bundestag herzlichen dank dafür
vielen dank auch an mike mohring die
mitarbeit bei deutschlands schnellster
meinungen die einordnungen ebenso nina
schenk hier bei uns im studio und ja
einen einblick an einem besonderen tag
an einem tag an dem zwei gibt plus im
bundestag beschlossen wurde da ging es
hoch her wir waren live dabei wünschen
ihnen noch eine wunderbaren tag sie da
tun wir doch oder auf jeden fall
wünschen wir ihnen wir sehen uns dann
morgen wieder danke tschüss